c'est l'histoire d'une longue remontée
vers la surface pour l'adaptation
théâtrale de vos quatre livres vous
présentée au théâtre du nouveau monde
le pièce de théâtre qui résume toute
votre vie
mais si vous vous pourquoi vous avez
fait ce choix-là de tout déballer le
tout raconté son fils d'un d'abord les
romains étaient peut-être un peu
impudique mais à ce niveau là mais pas
plus que d'être actrice être actrice
c'est très impudique
c'est à dire qu on on peut pas c'est
faux l'idée selon laquelle on se cache
derrière un personnage
lorsqu'un personnage dans la tragédie ou
d'un drame explose de douleur ou on veux
pas puiser sa à droite puis à gauche on
puise en ce qu'on est vraiment en soi et
donc c'est très impudique l'émotion vous
voyez traverser les acteurs sur scène
c'est réel c'est bien réel
on dit on joue on joue mais il faut bien
traiter notre sensibilité aux
personnages à l'eau je prends votre
réponse ou bon parce qu'on vous a vu au
cinéma à la télévision au théâtre j'ai
vu dans ma pétards tramway nommé désir
et en lisant votre premier livre parler
de la mort de roch votre ferr ou
m'envoyer vous aviez cinq ans j'ai un
peu l'impression que vous avez choisi ce
métier là justement pour incarner une
autre personne que vous parce que votre
peine et est lourde à porter c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on va résonner mais
bien entendu c'est pas sûr que je serais
devenue actrice sans cette tragédie
initiale dans ce grand de tension des
événements aussi terrible pour les
parents comme pour la fratrie que la
perte d'un enfant
il ya la vie avant puis à la vie après
alors ça notre monde a basculé vraiment
toute notre vie a changé
est ce que je serais devenue actrice
peut-être pas mais gégé j'ai eu le goût
de monter sur scène puis je révèle
beaucoup de choses d'un fleuve la vie
n'en finit plus de
ti nus et sans que tu reviennes ce qui
me fascine de vos oeuvres de votre vie
c'est que on le réinventer on n'y aurait
pas cru
peut-être sentiments vous avez reçu ben
non parce que ça a été notre vie ça a
été la vie de ma famille on connaît rien
d'autre que notre vie alors pour nous ça
a été ça vivre c'est vrai que quand
quand notre frère est devenu
schizophrène depuis que ça saigne à elle
très très difficile on disait souvent ça
c'est lourd c'est trop lourd il qu'on
disait souvent c'est lourd mais à part
ça on a on a fait face on a beaucoup
pleuré mais en même temps c'est notre
vie c'est notre vie à nous beaucoup
côtoyé la mort parce que votre mère
aussi il a aussi tout le monde et oui et
vous en 2010 avec un épuisement
professionnel oui au même moment où ma
soeur décliner puis morte en quelques
jours une succession d'avc parce que
c'est pour ça que vous avez commencé à
créer votre histoire à coucher sur
papier pour complètement complètement
c'est à dire que c'est suite aux bonnes
notes à mes quatre mois de convalescence
on dirait que le tout les pudeurs que
j'avais à écrire qui était mon rêve de
jeunesse sont toutes tombées
ça me semble ridicule d'attendre j'ai le
goût d'écrire alors j'écris ça lui ça a
été très bénéfique pour moi de de perdre
mes moyens
j'ai alors fait face à hamme on a ce
désir d'écrire puis c'est comme ça
qu'est né le fleuve le premier bébé et
puis ça s'éteint les ca sur son visage
son défi parce que jouer c'est toute
votre vie à cette époque où vous ne
pouviez plus jouer parce que vous était
trop malade sinon jouer c'est pas toute
ma vie ce qui est arrivé quelque chose
dans ma vie j'ai eu des enfants
et puis le le théâtre a pris la deuxième
place
ben oui à partir du moment où on a nos
enfants ce qu'ils avaient premières
places le théâtre est passé en deuxième
fait que c'est pas toute ma vie c'est
pas toute ma vie vous voyez la vie du
bon côté vraiment bien mais mes livres
sont beaucoup
une quête de lumière puis choisir d'être
actrice je le dis dans le spectacle
choisir d'être actrice s'était choisir
d'entrer dans la lumière les projecteurs
le regard sur soi l'écoutent
c'est fabuleux parce que le spectacle
nous est révélée différemment tous les
soirs parce que c'est jamais les mêmes
spectateurs et on apprend beaucoup des
nouveaux spectateurs on découvre le
spectacle d'une autre façon c'est sans
cesse nouveau s'est jamais pareil c'est
fabuleux
sylvie drapeau enchanté merci beaucoup à
vous pluriel tout concernant et
ordinaire toujours tu resteras celui qui
a été emporté par le fleuve toujours
nous resterons les survivants des routes
et hébétée